Okay, Upal Chopper
has taken on the form of becoming true here.His name is Tsutsuki Wagen and Tsukiyaku.Two Water
Priesthoods are one, and only when they are both in place does it
make sense.However, the whole form has changed,
it's been a while.  Oh
Dore The upper limit method is that if you succeed in a critical hit in battle with an opponent whose level is higher than yours, your
HP will
decrease, but the power of your next attack
will be adjusted, and your HP will recover under the same conditions.  It's
two in one.
This weapon, which accumulates a fusion gauge by landing critical attacks a certain number of times, can be
fused. Wow, that's serious. Mako, let's equip it right away and try it
out. Ah, the necessary status. Calm down, simple math.  It's a problem.The total number
of stats is 150.The total
number of stats is
571.Every time you increase the level, you get 5 points.I can
handle the equipment properly up to level 50.I've been
training
hard enough.
Use it
JA